so is it possible that Bella checks on a
walkie er and we don't even know it
is that possible my yeah yes absolutely
it's possible my supposition is that's
not the case and again from folks who
have told me I expect them both around
here in 2018 that leads me to believe
that he's not but but here's the scoop
to Tom
you know and I've you know dropped a
couple of breadcrumbs of on Twitter on
this - question is do we have a loaf or
not so but there's one job opening in
the NFL that would even give Belichick a
split second of thinking about that's
open right now and they also have the
number two overall pick and he knows and
he knows the family that runs it and the
Giants job is open I have no idea if
gentlemen would even entertain the idea
with whatever contract he has or the
Giants would even entertain it but you
have to think they would is there any
there there - that sort of sense Tom
that Belichick and everything would just
throw his hands up and say I'm just
gonna finish up my career somewhere else
like the Giants if you really besides
that at 6566 he wants a challenge I
think that would be a hell of a
challenge because you have to take Eli
Manning out behind the barn finish that
job then you have to find a new
quarterback then you have to find new
coordinators because Josh certainly
isn't coming with you
additionally you have to feel
comfortable working with Dave gentlemen
who in my mind is one serious no BS kind
of guy who has an idea of how we want to
do things I like the way gentlemen
operates he almost operates in a
Belichick Ian manner you know what I'm
in charge here but unless they share a
brain I don't know if those two old dogs
would necessarily be able to combine and
work together I don't know what the
relationship is but that's what I look
at what because belts are gonna want to
go in after gentlemen has probably been
given the keys to that franchise and
told to fix it and have to you know off
gentlemen listen - gentlemen that's why
I think that's kind of a non-starter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience
you